hey guys real quick before the video
this topic was highly requested but it's
also very controversial no matter where
you stand on this topic we think it's
really important to listen to people and
to be empathetic yes so let us know what
you think in the comments below we want
to move the dialogue forward and keep it
respectful enjoy the video
read-a-thon Bergin anyone younger they
live in the best environment that has
ever existed for human beings there's
never been a world that's more
nourishing more safe more full of
opportunity people are dying
collapsing we are in the beginning of a
mass extinction and all you can talk
about is money economic growth how dare
you I felt very uncomfortable watching
yesterday it was all a little
melodramatic many people especially
younger people are being misled
I see climate change arguments and
activists more as climate alarmists I
think I'm quite educated on this subject
I can't imagine anything that would
change my mind well I just wanted to be
here just to possibly inform people
about a more constitutional aspect of
this whole argument I am a healthy
skeptic not just on climate change but
in general a lot of things I think that
people are naturally alarmists and they
make things way worse than they actually
are I think the benefits of fossil fuel
use far outweigh the side effects
including our influence on the climate
[Music]
so I'm here on somewhat agree I care
about clean water I care about clean air
I don't think it should clean out your
wallet we can protect the green without
it without it costing a lot of green
that's what I like to say my real
problem is corrupt government that lines
its own pockets it ends up causing
pollution that's our problem really it's
hypocritical for many people to argue
that they care about the environment and
yet we see homelessness and we see trash
all over the place and you see that to
me is the environment I love nature I
spend a lot of time and my resources to
enjoy nature but I think of it from a
human centered perspective I want an
amazing world for human beings to live
and when people talk about the
environment they often talk about the
nonhuman environment the unaltered
environment and they think we shouldn't
change the environment and my whole
philosophy is no either we change the
environment dramatically or we die ready
you know what to be really honest with
you you'd have to knock down the wall
and put me in the street this is not far
enough if I could go I'd be like going
through the door the media is so corrupt
and I can't get out you guys
but that's how bad it is economic the
economic growth is stellar unprecedented
and they don't talk about it but if the
if the stock market went up ten points
under the Obama administration there'd
be fanfare about it for three days no
and and we have we have newspapers who
are saying they're not going to print
any skeptics letters or any articles
that are from skeptics so what the
minute that somebody says to me you
can't listen to this other side that's
what I'm gonna listen to that other side
that's why scriber started in the the
group that I contribute to and it was
because mainstream has shown that
there's so much bias out there now that
there needs to be somebody in the middle
that can cut through it I think it's
important that what we can call the
mainstream media they're they're sort of
attempting to do a job that's very
important we need expert knowledge to
make a lot of decisions in life
including decisions about energy and and
climate and we need know we need the
knowledge of different kinds of
specialists to inform those kinds of of
decisions I'm not ashamed to say that
I'm not the most educated person like
I'm not ashamed about that at all with
any subject at all and I think that's
healthy to admit some on education
unless you're like the most unless
you're the smartest person on the planet
so yeah I don't understand it completely
this just happens to be the issue I
spend my entire life on because with
most issues I put myself like way on
that side and I think it's important
one thing though with expertise that
comes up is if you're talking about
energy policy and and policies about
fossil fuels like the green New Deal
you don't just need climate experts you
need energy experts too because if
you're talking about oh this is gonna
happen in the climate I'm concerned
about that that's fine but you need to
know okay well if I restrict fossil fuel
use what's that going to do to people
although I'm not a scientist I do
believe that I am informed from the
perspective of constitutional you know
duty of government and which should be
limited and it should not be giving we
should not be giving away our
sovereignty to an international
okay that's very important and that's
what I see being done I I feel I'm
informed I've done a great deal of
reading including this gentleman's book
I've gone to a lot of conferences both
alarmist and skeptics so I think I've
and I and whenever I hear something that
I can't understand then I try to find
out what the the real answer is I know
you've done a lot of research on it and
so I don't think my knowledge base is as
large as yours but I still consider
myself strongly informed on this issue
because I've looked at the arguments
I've looked at the counter arguments
I've listened to people on the left on
the right climate change is real but
it's not something catastrophic it
doesn't require massive government
intervention and we shouldn't worry
about it yes well well Al Gore comes and
speaks to people about global warming he
has an entire about five or six SUVs
that are running the entire time he's
speaking plus the fact he flies all over
the the world in his private jet but
those who have money and they are
climate change activists I'd like to see
them put some of their bank account
empty their bank accounts put it into
the whole climate change
you know activism and then maybe I will
consider what they are saying Oh for me
I guess it depends on the act of its
activists you're talking about just cuz
I think that everyone's different so
they're gonna be you know you're talking
about people with money so yeah maybe
they're hypocritical I think that most
people are hypocritical in one way or
another and so I just feel kind of bad I
guess saying yeah you're hypocrites
jerks cuz I'm sure I'm hypocritical in
some ways but even with that said I
think that most of I believe most of the
activists I think there are advocates I
think that they're genuine I think that
they believe what they're doing and if
they could get rid of every car and
every plane and every everything that's
causing bad the environment they
probably would and they probably love it
we as in cubed should try to stop the
polar ice cap from LT three they melt
and refreeze all the time sometimes more
sometimes less but it's a natural
phenomenon we have nothing to do with it
how much of the planet is water compared
to landmass 71% okay so polar ice caps
melting yeah I mean I think the it's
quite clear that you know we don't need
to try and stop that from happening I
mean it's you know it's impossible they
try to play up the polar ice caps are
going to melt and certain islands are
gonna be submerged that is absolutely
nonsensical I'm not worried about it the
patterns I've been more clearly
demonstrated over smaller periods of
time we have nothing to worry about what
the polar ice caps
I think absent studying the facts on
this you can't have a definite
conclusion so I I disagree with the idea
that you know we can't have an impact on
it
I think theoretically you could you need
to look at what's the actual evidence of
what kind of impact can we have on it
and then very importantly what impact
will that have on human life
[Music]
you already go yeah sure we're talking
hypothetical here well for me it's like
saying if there was a volcano that's
gonna take out wipeout North America
would you get upset you like well of
course and if you can change it then do
it of course
so yeah something that big something
that catastrophic I mean that is huge
and that would change a lot in the world
I would be upset by that I mean yeah I
would be concerned by that for sure
sorry can I ask a quick follow-up
question really quick just like I'm just
totally curious because you talk about
human like the impact that has on humans
it sounds like you're Pro human over the
earth I'm just wondering to what extent
are you willing to go it's like for you
myself yes as a humanist who loves
nature and who loves the Earth's I think
the earth is an amazing place but I'm
thinking about it even when I think
about you know if I don't own land but I
live in a development I mean I think of
that as we should make that in a way
that's enjoyable for human beings and
sometimes that means preserving
something that's really beautiful or
magical but sometimes it means
dramatically transforming it I want
human beings to have a very positive
relationship with the rest of nature so
I want us to relate to the rest of
nature in a way that we benefit which
means of course preserving all the
amazing part of nature I think that's a
really important point you're bringing
up because I mean catastrophe ghin
language what is a catastrophe exactly
or is it a catastrophe for the animals
and plants as a contestant for human
beings I think a lot of these climate
alarmists and you know climate activists
they see the there's like a there's like
a religious thing they've practically
worship the planet in some degree or a
sense of guilt about oh it's my fault
that there's something bad that's gonna
happen to future generations they they
give an animist element to plants and
animals that's a considerable issue and
I think that's nonsensical and part of
the reason why we're skeptics we care
about human beings we care or we believe
in a divine order I certainly do
Oh
polar bears my favorite animal but so I
would go here if it was just that but I
would say that the best chance of polar
bears not going extinct is for human
beings to have low-cost energy because
what when we have low-cost energy we can
basically preserve anything that we want
oh no yeah well no holders I love polar
bears but I think that we have all kinds
of bears so there be other bears no
polar bears go extinct so what if we can
keep using fossil fuels they will have a
good in a good future because wind and
solar cannot cannot replace fossil fuels
it just can't there isn't enough there
isn't enough land mass for enough wind
and solar farms to replace fossil fuels
if we stop using them all together yeah
I mean I I say strongly disagree on the
on the premise that if we continue to be
relatively free including free to use
fossil fuels then the world would be a
much better place to live because the
common narrative which you certainly
hear from Greta Thun berg is basically
it amounts to if we are free to use
fossil fuels then the world is going to
end in my life is so bad Greta thunder
gand anyone younger they live in the
best environment that has ever existed
for human beings from a human
perspective there's never been a world
that's more nourishing more safe more
full of opportunity and fossil fuels are
fundamental because they've given us the
power to transform the naturally
deficient and dangerous environment into
an unnaturally abundant and safe
environments you know it's it's all
disasters so every little natural
disaster that happens like fires in
Australia or fires in Northern
California they blame it on global
warming they claim blame it on climate
change and that causes people because
again the media pushes that narrative
and then people of course believe it
because they don't have any other
information that can counter that
well I move
I was going to say I didn't think that
the environment would be a situation for
future generations but I'm going to take
this from an a completely different
perspective of the way that the youth is
trending right now in climate movements
it's going at a alarming rate and if
things do change and they do allow
policy decisions based on you know some
incomplete data or regressive policies
it's going to end up creating an
environment that's like a third-world
country that is anti-human that is
putting people back in a bad environment
where it's a threatening environment so
my basic thought is I think that the
world is much more bigger and important
than people or anything that people
could do to the environment obviously
people have an effect on the world and
the environment with what they do in
their actions but I think the world's
going to last a lot longer than people
ever will
while I said I was willing to listen to
arguments I have for probably at least
10 years I have yet to see one that
would change my mind and I have yet to
see data that would change my mind but I
will look at new data a data if someone
shows it to me I don't think we've been
able to have an honest conversation
about climate change since the 70s or
the 80s and even though I was born in
mid 80s I think we need to have an
honest conversation and I'm willing to
change my mind but it's not at the
expense of any policies that will be
anti-human yeah I will not change my
mind I'm pretty much set my my personal
faith I believe in the inerrancy I
believe the immutable laws of nature
apply and cannot be changed because I
believe in the Scriptures the Bible and
basically in Genesis as long as it says
that the earth abides as long as the
earth abides four seasons
will not cease but I would say that
there with the increasing amount of
scientific secular research that is on
this topic it has become more
prevalently evident to me that climate
change despite its reality despite its
variances over hundreds of years not
just over a few years it's become
emphatically consistently so that it's
not going to lead to any catastrophes
that it's not going to lead to a massive
decimation of the human species I don't
think there's many things that I
wouldn't be open to changing my mind to
just depending on the evidence and and
seeing I feel like it's being on a jury
of like a murder case like I'm going to
look at the evidence and I'm gonna make
the best decision I can't based on the
evidence and so based on the evidence
that we have right now like my opinion
is set but that could always change I
think we should always be open to the
facts changing but the current facts are
so decisive in favor of humanity needs
more fossil fuels going forward to have
a livable planet for eight billion
people that if you're challenging that
you're you're challenging 200 years of
fossil fuels improving human life and
the fact that there are no viable
alternatives for the next couple decades
[Applause]
[Music]